do I always want to pursue this is this
like a another girlfriend my dad had or
like what's the original popcorn branch
[Music]
we have
am I the butthole am I the 45 bucks hole
45 bucks yeah I told everybody about
that and they think it's the funniest
thing ever
45 bucks hole Taiko is like kind of a
genius yeah all right am I the butthole
for selling my deceased parents house
without telling my sibling all right
that's the title oh [__] wait without
telling me one sibling inherited we need
the contest here we go okay because I'm
like how can they sell it this is it
I'll I'll read the story quickly even
though it's very detailed okay but then
after that I'll tell you what
they are the [__] and my mom did the
same [__] and I told my mom you're the
[__]
foreign
[Music]
they're supposed to write hey everyone
I'm struggling with the dilemma and I'm
not sure if I'm the [__] in this
situation my parents passed away a few
months ago and I inherited their house
so I'm a 35 year old female and my
sibling is a 32 year old male we haven't
spoken in years due to some past issues
and we've never had a great relationship
oh yeah you're the [__] now I could
tell I could totally tell okay after my
parents passing I decided to sell the
house it needed a lot of repairs
maintenance and I didn't want to deal
with it I found a buyer and sold the
house for a good price however I never
told my sibling about the sale nor did I
offer to split the proceeds with them
to give
it didn't tell them [__] to give some
background my relationship with my
sibling has been strained for a long
time we grew up together but we were
never close we had different interests
and personalities and we often fought
and argued as we got older things only
got worse we had some major conflicts
that led to us cutting off contact
completely when my parents passed away I
was the one who took care of everything
I planned the funeral dealt with the
paperwork and sorted out their finances
it was difficult and emotional time for
me but I felt I had to step up and take
charge my sibling didn't offer to help
or contribute in any way
so when I decided to sell the house I
didn't feel like I needed to involve my
sibling they hadn't been in touch with
my parents for years and they hadn't
shown any interest in the house or their
belongings I assumed they wouldn't care
what happened to it recently my sibling
found out about the sale and is furious
with me they're saying that I had no
right to sell the house without their
knowledge or consent and that I'm being
greedy by keeping all the money for
myself they're demanding that I split
the proceeds with them even though they
never contributed anything to the house
or helped with repairs I feel like I had
every right to sell the house since it
was legally mine and I didn't want to
involve my sibling because of our past
issues however I can see how they might
feel hurt or left out so am I the
butthole for not telling my sibling
about the sale and keeping all the money
for myself yes I don't need your stupid
background story about how you don't
talk to them anymore it was your it was
the house of their parents right well
when they say legally theirs because in
the will only they're supposed to
inherit it
because if that's the way it is that's
what the parents wanted and all you're
doing is executing with the parents I
think the key is if if he didn't
contact the parents that's kind of like
you're strange at that point you
divorced your own parents yeah and then
also you weren't a part of contributing
to the funeral and you weren't a part of
the process then you decided to abandon
them you ask yourself out kind of so are
you entitled to any of it or is it her
story because I can also see this going
where she just took initiative and did
all this stuff and then she didn't
communicate either and she was like oh
that [__] didn't do anything and
offered anything we don't know because
this is her point of view and with her
[__] paragraph of justifications as
to like why she's estranged to him
sounds weird to me exactly that was an
eyebrow accessory for me
Big Time huge ancestry I think there's a
85 chance she's the [__]
what is it what is everybody's official
vote based off of that information I go
87 chance my official vote doubling down
my official vote is what's on the will
says that
or if they didn't even prepare a will
right and it just went to next to Kin
which is the older sister or whatever
then he never had a chance to be on the
will
the second line from that is is she
telling the truth that he was not in
contact with them for several years how
long and like yeah because that tells me
a lot too because you gotta at least
talk to your parents [__] a
relationship yeah and then be at their
funeral yeah is the brother a dancer
because that would help me make the
decision
okay so you know how with these am I the
[__] things there's um the the bot or
whatever tells you to also put like a
almost a summary of like the situation
yeah okay so the person has offered the
following exploration for why they think
they might be the [__] and you're
supposed to write that and at the bottom
says the action I took was selling my
deceased parents house without telling
my estranged sibling and keeping all the
money for myself I might be seeing as an
[__] in this situation because my
sibling is technically entitled to a
share of The Inheritance even though we
have a strained relationship this
[__] switching up words because
if you said I legally own it and then
they're entitled to it it's like what is
it dude correct and then they said
technically entitled yeah but now
informing my sibling about the sale I'm
not offering to split the proceeds I
might be seen as acting selfishly and
disrespecting my siblings rights as a
beneficiary even though my sibling
didn't offer any help or support during
that it doesn't matter they didn't
delegate first of all yeah they didn't
like reach out to Subway and go can you
handle this or whatever the [__] yeah
they just assumed all control and then
go I get all the profits yeah you didn't
even help me I think that's what people
do normally people actually do that
because they because them reaching out
and trying to work together
collaboratively on a situation like that
is probably like a out for them where
they go [__] that I'm just gonna do it
myself and then be like oh well you
didn't help because that's easier
190 [__] that's almost 200 percent
yeah according to my [__] why not I know
I know it's gonna make it 200 but tell
us where you're at what do you mean like
I know it's gonna make it 200 but why
are you 190
because of what was just said exactly
why are you looking at me you know who
the real [__] doesn't have to answer
the question have you been eating
I think they're real
it's so confusing
it's not just taste I think the real
[__] the parents
because we're not making it clear for
dating yeah yeah that too or leaving a
mess how dare you die yeah if you know
that your kids are [__] fighting and
not talking if you know you have a a
strained relationship with your son then
you need to [__] create a good exit
strategy if you know you're about to die
yeah unless it happens suddenly
because other than that you're just a
lazy [__] if you're old and you already
know like you're not 40 years old you
know
[__] them [__] these [__] them [__] the
parrots you know what the parents are
the [__] good answer maybe the
brother's the only chill one and he's
like I gotta get out of here maybe
though right because maybe you know
at the end of the day
when people took this for face value a
lot of people in the comments are like
you're not the [__] right and then as
you keep on going down the comments
suddenly you'll start to see somebody be
like well where's the will what is the
will actually that's the number one
thing yeah yeah that's my first go-to is
what's the parents wishes right then you
go down you're like you know you you
read people who are paying attention to
more details and they're like well you
said you legally owned it here but over
here you're saying that the brother is
entitled to a part of the inheritance
because whatever your relationship is to
your brother has nothing to do with the
The Inheritance it's their relationship
to the parents and the fact that they're
doing that it shows me they don't really
probably have an argument and they're
trying to justify emotions to it to
convince me something and I hate that
[__] it's like oh he's been an [__]
yeah he deserves it girl that doesn't
hold up in in court either it doesn't
it's all about Birthright it doesn't
mean you have to maintain a relationship
with anybody what are the facts and then
when the emotions aren't favorable
the user deleted their account
interesting you know what's crazy dead
people do leave a [__] big mess so I
thought my dad did a pretty good job
because he had a will and it's like uh
this week I want you to do whatever it
is where I want to get buried he has
everything stated in there and then in
the burial section it had like maybe
like five plots of other places to be
buried so I thought that was like okay
cool like he wants the family to be
together so maybe if his brother gets
passes away or whoever that's who
um like like they're gonna be buried at
the same place when we went to the
cemetery and I'm like oh I just want to
confirm all these burial plots and then
out of the five only one was reserved
for my dad and he goes oh he actually
sold the other four
and I was like what he never told me
that [__] and then I was like who this
sold to and you're like oh I did some
like person named ping ping pow or some
[__] and I was like who the [__] is
shirts made so I'm like I don't even
know who that is and I'm like do I even
want to like pursue this like I think
better than ping ping pow you should
definitely look into that sounds like a
fake company dude I don't even want to
pursue this is this like a another
girlfriend my dad had or like what's the
other right popcorn brand
yeah what did he trade it for I don't
know
I think he has assets that are missing
could be yeah it could be
[__] ping-ping I found 10 G's in his
[__] sweatpants what the heck I don't
know if he was like going cuckoo on his
last limb or whatever but like so when
it happened I went to my my mom's house
and obviously it's like a huge mystery
right because we all know how he went
out so I'm like okay there's got to be a
no like what the [__] is going on so I
went through all of his blinds like
Pockets pockets of blazers pockets of
sweatpants luggage small Pockets big
Pockets literally anywhere is he hiding
[__] anywhere under the the carpeting of
the uh the floor carpet of his car like
is there like I'm look I was I was
searching as if like I was a detective
like looking everywhere yeah and then he
this [__] had like a random like
rolled up 10 G's in his [__]
sweatpants I'm like you've only been
rolling around with like 10 G's in your
sweatpants dude what if pink pink pal
[__] assassinated him
at my mom's house
I mean maybe that's like you gotta find
out who ping ping no no Joe keep going
further dude do you think that the pal
family when they had their baby
they're like
ping pang I think they're both like yeah
hell yeah or white guy's like Ping the
other the wife's like pain
and then
this movie written by white guys
[Music]